من مرحله لاخرى تحاول الصين تجاوز عقبه
كورونا وبخطا مثقله باعباء الوضع الصحي
تعلن عن انتهاء الذروه موجه تفشل قاسيه
فاوفقا لنائبه رئيس الوزراء الصيني صارت
الجائحه بشكل عام في البلاد عند مستوى
منخفض نسبيا
عدد الحالات الحرجه في المستشفيات تتناقص
بشكل متضرد والجائحه اصبحت عند مستوى
منخفض لكن مهمه الانقاذ لا تزال ثقيله
الاعلان الرسمي عن تحسن الاوضاع الصحيه
يتزامن مع عطله راس السنه القمريه الجديده
وفي يوم يعد احد اكثر ايام السفر ازدحاما
منذ فش الجائحه عام 2019
يتخوفوا لبعض من زياده اخرى في عدد
الاصابات بسبب حركه السفر والتنقلات
تخوفات لم يخفيها الرئيس الصيني في جنبينج
الاسبوع الماضي لا بد من بدل المزيد من
الجهود لتحسين رعايه الطبيه للفئات
المعرضه للاصابه بالفيروس في المناطق
الريفيه ومعالجه مواقف في الوقايه من
الاوبئه في هذه المناطق
التصريحات الرسميه الصينيه وتوجه اليابان
بخفض تصنيف كورونا الى فئه الانفلونزا
خلال الربيع القادم
لقد اكدت مع حكومتي على تعزيز المناقشات
بين الخبراء حول خطوات اعاده تصنيف فيروس
كورونا الجديد وخفضي فئه المرض الى الفئه
خمسه في هذا الربيع ارقام المؤسسات الصحيه
العالميه تتماشى مع تحذيرات منظمه الصحه
العالميه حول تطورات كورونا في العالم حيث
اشارت الى ارتفاع نسبه الوفيات الى 20% في
الفتره ما بين ديسمبر الماضي ويناير
الجاري مقارنه بالايام الثمانيه والعشرين
التي سبقت هذه الفتره الى جانب انخفاض
نسبه الاصابات بنحو 7%
اما السلطات الصحيه الصينيه فتواصل سعيها
لاحتواء المرض كان اخره حصول شركه
سينوفارم الصينيه على موافقه الاستخدام
لقاح ضد متحول اوميكرون
علي السمان العربيه